der 73
parteitag der fdp
ich sprach mit den bekanntesten köpfen
der freidemokraten ist aber egal wenn
man auf den titan der fdp trifft doktor
rudi renschler es gibt sie noch die
guten dinge herr renschler von der fdp
saar wie schön ja ist richtig ich habe
ja was sind ihre faszinierenden
vorschläge um die fdp wieder für ältere
leute zu begeistern
leute begeistern da muss erst einmal die
rentenbesteuerung von der
doppelbesteuerung befreit werden dann
darf die polizei keine jagd auf ältere
autofahrer machen man hört zu wenig von
ihnen letzten zeit ist ist dass der
trend der zeit dass die fdp die einfach
die älteren die rechtschaffenden die was
geleistet haben für die partei einfach
weghaben will das einzige was fehlt das
ist die heute show die ist immer auf
mich zugekommen ich weiß nicht warum die
ist immer gemacht haben deshalb hat ihn
war ich so bekannt aber ich werde
überall also mit offenen armen empfangen
ist heute show redet nicht mehr mit
ihnen ich weiß du hast keine ahnung wie
heute show kam also über die jahrzehnte
ja jedes war auf mich zu ja und dann
derweil hat mal
wie und jetzt jetzt jetzt auf einmal
kommen die gar nicht mehr was war das
denn für vögel die da mit ihnen geredet
und der hat mich und haben mich dann
auch einmal ich werde im ausland hat
mich sogar ausfindig gemacht haben
angerufen
bewusst dazu ob ich direkt in der
heutigen show kommen wolle habe ich
danke ich lasse mich doch nicht durch
den kakao ziehen na ja nicht von diesem
welcher diesen dahergelaufenen fernsehen
fritzen da und so würde ich das nicht
nur eine chance feiner kerl also nehme
man sollte ja alle leute das ausgleicht
behandeln das stimmt ja zumal er und
kollege ist hier zdf ja also ich kann
mich überhaupt nicht beklagen also auf
meine stimme würde auch in der partei
gehört aber aber die idee auf ihre
stimme wird eine partei gehört aber die
heute-show redet nicht mehr mit ihnen
fühlt man sich da so ein bisschen aufs
abstellgleis
gestellt also was fehlt ein politiker
wenn man nicht mehr von der heute-show
interviewt wird
das waren stück zusätzliche bekanntheit
ja man sozusagen gratis bekommen also
ich hab die gratis bekommen und das ist
jetzt immer da also es war immer schön
wenn ich da irgendwo also gezeigt worden
mal dass deine freundin hat sich immer
sehr gesehen erfolge
helfen
vielleicht kommt ja eines tages eine
gute fee und bringt sie wieder an die
heute show ja gut noch besser war vor
zwei jahren
kam ich mal von 50 sekunden in berlin
direkt vom parteitag das war echt daher
dass das das ist natürlich ein global
also wenn man da in berlin direkt dass
ich meine da kann man zehn stunden genau
heute show auftreten okay aber zehn
sekunden bei berlin direkt fernsehkunden
ich weiß nicht mal mehr wie zehn jahren
und das ist natürlich ein ritterschlag
naja hat mich also das hat mich am
meisten gefreut ja nicht so diese heute
show und
dann nimmt man so mit über 50 sekunden
vielen dank dankeschön wie es geht es
nach draußen bisschen biden vertreten
sie gucken gerade woher ich komme ja sie
kommen
können sie mir sagen wann holen sodass
ausstrahlen soll wenn alles gut läuft
deshalb annika
bünder sie noch gibt
da gezeigt
so kinder ich hoffe die kamera läuft
denn ich halte nicht an abonniert den
kanal hier danke euer gernot hassknecht
so ich gehe wieder nach hause
schönen feierabend jürgen zschau